on Monday evenings people gather in
Dresden to demonstrate against what they
decry as the Islamisation of the West
they've been doing so for two years now
Ludvik Renault comes almost every week
to observe and to tweet he and his
colleagues post on Twitter under the
name stars angus richer in English
Street coverage I Spit sermon is tuned
Kennison what we can do is create an
awareness of what really goes on here
under the guise of civilized society
that's what people actually say here and
how much hatred of foreigners there
really is in this movement we document
that and publish it document en masse
BFF in position does on this one evening
Ludwik hey not issues 22 tweets Street
coverage has 17,000 followers the
potential for violence that these
demonstrations shouldn't be
underestimated the target this time is
Chancellor Angela Merkel by now Ludwick
Renault is well known here the fact that
we're filming the demonstration
evidently doesn't bother the man on the
right he's come over to caution a day
not not to cause any more trouble
Reynold denies he's ever made trouble
answers
but this man says many of the
demonstrators no they not and his
political position and react allergic
Lee to him he suggests this alone might
be cause for trouble the outfit that
organises these rallies is known as
pegida the percentage of neo-nazis is
higher in saxony than in any other
german state pegida reflects and perhaps
bolsters the extreme right there the
contrast is stark much of dresden is
spectacularly beautiful against this
elegant backdrop racism and right-wing
extremism are evidently flourishing its
representatives claim that there are too
many foreigners and that they're a bad
thing in fact just six percent of
dresden's residents are foreign
nationals each year almost two million
tourists are visiting Greyston to see
the sights the accusation that its
inhabitants are hostile to foreigners
are very bad for the city and its image
last week's or bomb attacks on a mosque
and a conference center in dresden
nobody was injured the police are
working on the assumption that the
motive was xenophobia bankin new thought
Ludvik a note went to the mosque after
the attack and talked to members of the
muslim community i'm the i'm diggin
d'ivoire on demon spawn secure a living
here in dressin I've lived here in
Dresden for 20 years and have never
experienced anything like it Dresden is
such a beautiful city why would some
people want to spoil things this is
unprecedented and I don't want to see
anything like it happened again won't
even eat normal Xion so us fennel
reported both on what happened and on
people's reactions it's heightened
standoff something like this had been
brewing for a while we don't yet know
who carried out the attacks the obvious
assumption is that it was anti-foreigner
the potential is certainly there so it's
not a surprise that something like this
has happened aspesi oats
there's another side to Dresden
cosmopolitan creative welcoming the
start shall be 0 state theatre hosts a
cafe every Monday for locals and
refugees with a range of activities
including theatre workshops a woman's
cafe a program for children talks and
discussions tool it is the speech DSP on
stars yeah it's important for us as a
theater to take a stand insane there are
values we believe in and we want to live
by together actively at the Monday cafe
and out in the community and many
ordinary citizens of Dresden take part
in the Monday cafe up to 300 people come
over the course of this evening people
here admit that hostility to foreigners
is a problem in the eastern parts of
Germany but now people opposed to that
ride ring rhetoric are growing more
assertive they say we're in the majority
we just have to learn how to speak up
the Monday cafe is really catching on
what is him up may I ask why you're here
today violet advice gig because I
dislike xenophobia what is spilling I
enjoy playing with the people here it's
wonderful to someone does it's wunderbar
playing games to overcome hostility
sometimes life can be so simple
you